cg les jaunes pour certains sont là
depuis le début du mouvement ils se
relaient en permanence
en bourgogne la situation est un peu
plus calme que les jours précédents
puisque les préfectures n'ont pas lancé
dallaire par rapport à des situations de
blocage il ya un seul centre
départemental opérationnelle qui reste
en activité
7 jours sur 7 24 heures sur 24 c'est
celui de la saône et loire
on va écouter lundi si les gens qui va
nous expliquer ses motivations on écoute
on est déterminés on est nombreux là et
on est une légion une petite légion ici
mais il ya une grosse lésion dans toute
la france les gens sont déterminés on
ira jusqu'au bout on va pas lâcher c'est
c'est plus un jeu en fait ainsi le
président voit ça comme un jeu faut bien
qu'ils se disent que les gens ici
lâcheront rien
leschi les jaunes dont qui sont ici à ce
ph m'ont dit qu'ils en 2058 ticket de
péage comme celui ci qu'ils ont
accumulés depuis vendredi 14 heures
auxquelles il faut ajouter environ 5000
véhicules qui n'ont pas été
comptabilisés ils sont donc déterminés à
poursuivre le mouvement comme je vous le
disais coûte que coûte